although i'm at Davos at best in any
life I'm an ordinary person who it feels
the outrage that many people do most
people do when they hear of the CEOs
receiving huge bonuses eighteen point
four billion dollars in bonuses for 2008
performance or lack of performance and I
think I reflect the outrage of the
ordinary citizen who feels very strongly
about the notion that we were told that
CEOs require those kinds of pay packages
because they are tied to performance and
then we find out that essentially the
notion of corporate welfare is stronger
than the notion of corporate performance
so I believe very strongly that the
average taxpayer in the US must demand a
code of ethics for corporations that in
fact if we are tied to the notion of
paying very very high figures so far
outside the understanding of an ordinary
taxpayers ordinary person wage earner
that in fact they do thi very strongly
to performance and that they tie to a
code of ethics that that in fact
reflects the values of ordinary citizens
thank you